thank you very much
we will suspend business at this point
I found myself in the the bizarre place
that I was actually hoping there might
be another intervention to the gallery
just to stop that long run from Hamza
Yusuf that didn't address the question
at all because I specifically asked here
they go
we will suspend
uh Hamza Yusuf had a script prepared
there he read it Ad nauseam
and I'll try and continue if you want to
try and continue your presiding officer
because Hamza Yusuf read out a script
specifically about an independence
Minister within his government I think I
will have to to spend Mr Ross
unfortunately we will suspend business
I know he can't see the faces behind him
that we can we can see the reaction of
his back Ventures to his contribution
here
we will suspend
Hannah called Douglas Ross thank you
very much a presiding officer
to you
we will suspend
thank you that concludes first
Minister's questions I would just like
to say at this point colleagues that I
deeply regret that due to the completely
unacceptable interruptions that we've
experienced today I'm unable to call any
more members to put questions to the
first Minister on matters of importance
to the people that they represent